alors non mais je sais pas si c'est
quelque chose qui s'est vraiment passé
où quelque chose que j'ai rêvé je pense
que j'en avais rêvé en fait donc j'étais
chez vous c'est que j'adore les
activités aquatiques dont j'avais fait
un petit jacuzzi ouais je suis allé me
coucher alors chez moi pas vraiment chez
moi oui aux reds avaient un petit studio
c'était dans la piscine municipale à
côté
je suis allé me coucher mais seul dans
ma chambre ouais tu me suis rendormi oui
et un moment j'ouvre les yeux et je vous
vois entièrement nu face à moi oui en
train de dire ça à frérot comme ça et
après je me suis rendormi dont est-ce
que ça s'est vraiment passé est ce que
cette scène a eu lieu oui ou non et
pourquoi vous étiez nu dans ma chambre
alors que j'étais seul moi je vole bien
là je n'étais pas du jeune est venu
j'avais une serviette et travailler les
gens
[Rires]
c'est vrai que je n'ai je dis ça à
frérot ouais il adresse dont il a dormi
à la maison voilà parce que j'avais
besoin d'eux on était entre eux savent
et c'est là qu'on a fait la grille
montrer qu'il est un succès d'ailleurs
ah oui avec toute l'équipe de ses huit
aboutir et vincent pujol francs capitaux
ils ont tous deux remis à la maison miu
dastan ya eu jacoby
nous de nous deux est une aventure des
français la conséquence d'une partie
fine la nuit
non je vous le dis et je tends serviette
et je voulais voir si tout le monde
dormait bien skié dollars c'est vrai que
je suis à me suis rendu dans chacune des
chambres chacune des chambres - d'après
lui oui exactement et j'aurais pu si
cette phrase
voilà et vous n'étiez pas le seul voilà
non alors que moi j'ai une histoire
racontée avec vous aussi
dû m'aider à faire
lagarde n'ont pas bougé ramos avait juré
à cacher une fois on est allé à l'hôtel
tous les deux à bord avec ses vrais
l'après midi le soir soit est-ce qu'on
est désormais avec lui pour un gage oui
là vous essayez un peu de raconter
l'histoire votre manière alors c'est
vrai c'est un gars je le voyais pas
évident mais avec toi non plus à vous et
à la fin du gaz donc je reprends vos
mots pour une fois et c'est assez rare
vous m'avez ramener en voiture vous
sonné on a fait le chemin ensemble ah
oui vous souvenez pardon pas du tout
alors il met maintenant lamborghini
noire ça veut dire que dans la rolls pas
du tout pas des morts sélectives ont pas
du tout une voiture assez spacieuse ont
regardé la tv c'est la rolls à la tv
dans la voiture
[Rires]
et dans le van leeuw dans le var les
vitres étaient teintées on était tous
les deux et j'ai senti à un moment et je
voudrais savoir si je me trompe
[Rires]
maintenant est ce que tu as senti on
s'est arrêté longuement je vous ai
attendu mais lady bouge pas et à ce
moment là vous êtes revenu
alors vous avez l'air gêné mais yahia
c'est pas la peine cyril ans
oui douter à la fin à la faim avait
laissé partir oui et j'ai senti une
pointe de regret shanoa baba
je vous confirme que non
de soulagement voilà vous avez pris ça
pour du regret oui oui on pourra mettre
une dernière on peut continuer
l'émission dancing c'est là totalement
véridique ouais là aussi un petit peu
plus ont payés à la 6e année de tpm p
ont terminé mission il y avait un bras
et je voudrais me faire démaquiller vous
arriver et oui mais
l'histoire est vraie vous avez mis ça
dans nos bureaux allez on passe à autre
chose non content ou pas celle là non
non je crois ça le soit pas
trop comment cette émission aujourd'hui
ça y est mais il ya où je sais pas
quelle mouche vous a piqué mais rien à
boire à temps car on avait franchi un
palier parce qu'à las vegas avait
parcouru tout le talent mais vous avez
un slip c'est vrai à poil
actuellement un ipod futur il
ne vous dis que ça bah écoute elle est
excitée va bien voilà merci en tout cas
pour tous et ouais on fait le yoyo et
une boîte a plus qu'à ça fait très chaud
de lundi à jeudi voilà je vous le dis et
je vais balancer énormément de choses
que vous vous
surtout toi et amanda lear un nom
tourisme embêté ouais j'ai d'autres
détails ah oui pardon vous avez une
petite lampe de poche en fait pour
regarder s'il y avait quelqu'un dans le
lit oui c'est vrai mais personne
évidemment vous avez des invités pour
voir si j'avais un surveillant lui est
au chez moi c'est comme ça ça va pas non
mais s'il avait ramené quelqu'un comme
ça je vérifie et je suis allé vérifier
toutes les chambres le nouveau vérifiée
nulle avec une lampe ici
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
blatter n'a pas ce que c'est très grand
faut bien qu'ils se dirigent ouais ouais
ouais visiblement il est grand de
pied-à-terre c'est vrai je me rappelle
aussi alors je le dis tout castany qui
est venu chez moi un jour c'est vrai et
et il était on est à table et images et
avec mon ami jean en chine il y avait il
y avait pire est qu'il y avait avait
votre femme il ya un an rachida y avait
une autre copine anne où il va on est
une petite équipe de tpm paix et un
moment benjamin castaldi je vous le dis
on va parler d'augmentation et le tout
est monté ce soit c'est vrai cette
lancée m c'est vrai c'est pas ton s'est
rendu au néon rien que la vérité et mon
ami jean rachid vient me voir et il me
dit j'ai peur que ça dégénère non qu'on
se retrouve a enterré les corps dans le
jardin
c'est vrai donc il a pris pas chamakh
ndani ils sont partis ensemble de la
maison c'est vraiment au casino c'est
vrai exact avec votre voiture exactement
oui et de skoda et
et castaldi a perdu tout losail de mon
ami vrai ou pas c'est vrai voilà c'est
vrai absolument et cette mode normal ils
m'ont appelé à trois heures du matin
parce que ils ne trouvaient plus le
chemin pour revenir à fait vrai c'est
vrai c'est donc qu'ils étaient perdus et
voilà m et pèse sur le sur la skoda et
moi j'étais tranquillement en train de
danser avec votre femme
je peux même vous dire comment vous avez
négocié après l'augmentation va rester
quoi bon jeu s'est mis à poil oui bon
alors
ça veut dire des jeunes ont été mis à
poil ah ah bah oui oui c'est vrai que
mon cul est servi de cible c'est vrai
bah moi aussi c'est vrai vous vous
rappelez il a eu une augmentation
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai je vais venir jamais un jeu
c'est à dire combien je je le dis voyage
ont tiré des cartes celui qui a la plus
petite carte devait se mettre contre le
mur placé nul assez on devait tirer avec
des flèches voilà les faits je ne crois
pas il se trouve que je gagnais souvent
voilà et oui je la même déclinaison avec
le goal choix
c'est vrai aussi à des balles de golf
dans la gamme dans la gueule
derrière allez merci